hi I'm the executive director of the IRC
Institute we fund data-driven objective
research both practitioner and academic
research in just four years our award
has grown to be a centerpiece of this
event last year spark coverage not just
in the Wall Street Journal the New York
Times but editorials in the Wall Street
Journal at times and CNBC so it actually
shouldn't surprise me but it did that
the last two speakers and panels were
perfect lead ins to the two awards the
first award is the academic prize i
should note that these club not only
with a lovely crystal award but with ten
thousand dollars so we actually get good
submissions from people and the winning
academic research is passive investors
not passive owners and this demonstrates
that while passive investors such as
index funds are active owners in the
traditional sense of buying or selling
using exit the research finds that index
funds use large voting blocks to
exercise material effects on corporate
governance of public companies i will
leave the details of those effects to
Ian Appel what for boston college
professor of finance who will be
presenting the findings Ian's co-authors
on this hour todd gormley at Wharton and
Donald calm at Wharton I should note
that it's very it Scott stringer
provided a perfect lead-in to this would
he was talking about his proxy access
project and why they did it because they
owed everything we just heard about
universal orders diversified versus not
diversified and they don't have the
ability to sell and what they need is
some place to put 150 5 billion dollars
to earn something about
the rate of inflation or at their
actuarial interest rate forever and so
they try in our bilsteins words to get
the herd to run and I think professor
Appel and his co-authors demonstrate the
methods in which they do that and with
that I'd be glad to present this award
to you all right thank take a picture
later in the meantime there's the award
okay well I guess we'll take a picture
Dell is thanks all right thank you very
much John it's an honor to be here as
John said this is a joint work with Todd
Gormley and Don chyme at Wharton now the
title of the paper is passive investors
not passive owners and I think John did
a good job of summing up what this is
about the idea is pretty simple we're
just saying that just because you follow
a passive investment strategy does not
necessarily mean that you're passive in
terms of your views on governance and
ultimately how you engage with managers
we actually borrow this title from an
article written by Glenn Boreum at
Vanguard which he argues that Vanguard
cares quite a bit about corporate
governance and takes a number of actions
to ensure compliance with what they view
as strong governance practices now by
passive institutional investors we mean
these large institutional investors who
hold diversified portfolios designed to
mimic the returns of a particular index
as we see by the figure on this slide
passive ownership has increased
dramatically from about ten percent in
1998 all the way up to over thirty
percent by 2014 now it's not necessarily
clear if this is a good thing for
instance there was a cover article in
The Economist back in February which
wrote that a rising chunk of the stock
markets it's to the hands of lazy
investors index funds and
exchange-traded funds mimic the markets
movements and typically take little
interest in how firms are run now it's
worth noting that passive investors have
aggressively tried to push back against
this idea so in this paper we're asking
dude the passive investors effect
corporate governance there's certainly
reasons to think why the answer to this
may be no first off these passive
investors since they're unwilling to
accumulate shares or exit their
positions they may lack influence
furthermore they may lack motivation if
they're only trying to mimic markets
returns and so they may not care about
the returns of one particular stock
however there's other reasons to think
that passive institutions may in fact
strengthen corporate governance so first
off these investors have a fiduciary
duty to their own investors furthermore
they may be motivated if fund flows
respond not only to absolute to relative
to poor performance but also to absolute
performance and finally these investors
argue that since they're unable or
unwilling to eggs of their positions
they care even more about corporate
governance than other types of investors
now ultimately answering this question
poses an empirical challenge and this is
for the simple reason that correlation
does not imply causation that is we may
be worried about that firms with higher
passive ownership are different in other
ways so for instance they could have
higher active ownership as well now in
order to disentangle these effects we
need to use what economists refer to as
a natural experiment that is we need
some sort of quasi random variation in
passive ownership so in this paper what
we're going to do is we're going to use
variation in passive ownership generated
by the cutoff between the Russell 1000
and the russell 2000 indices so briefly
these indices are constructed each June
when Russell ranks the top three
thousand stocks according to market
capitalization it then cuts off the top
1000 stocks and calls at the Russell
1000 and uses the next 2,000 stocks as
the Russell 2000 index it's worth
pointing out that Russell has changed
this methodology in recent years but
we're only looking at the period from
when this is precisely what they were
doing now it's important to note that
these indices are value waited and so
portfolio weights will vary considerably
around this threshold this is
demonstrated in the following slide
so in the first panel we're plotting the
portfolio waits for the bottom 500 firms
in the Russell 1000 index and in the
second panel we're plotting the weights
for the top 500 firms in the Russell
2000 now as you would expect there's a
large jump in portfolio weights for
stocks that are at the top of the
Russell 2000 now it turns out there's a
similar amount of assets tracking these
two indices and so ultimately passive
ownership will be higher for stocks at
the top of the Russell 2000 and this is
demonstrated by the following figure so
here we're just taking the 500 the
bottom 500 stocks in the Russell 1000
and the top 500 stocks in the Russell
2000 and then we're just lining them up
by market capitalization and as you
would expect there's a break in passive
ownership at the cutoff between the two
indices and specifically passive
ownership which we're measuring using
mutual fund Holdings here is about sixty
six percent higher now we're altima tlie
interested in studying how these passive
investors influence governance we
specifically focus on governance
outcomes that are explicitly mentioned
by passive investors as being important
aspects of corporate governance so what
we find is that passive ownership is
associated with more independent
directors we also find that passive
ownership is associated with a higher
likelihood of removing anti-takeover
provisions so these could be things like
poison pills or restrictions on
shareholders calling special meetings
and finally we find that firms have
fewer dual-class shares when passive
ownership is higher so there's one share
one vote and this is a very another
another common thing that passive
investors talk about we next look at
what are the possible mechanisms that
allow passive investors to have this
influence so one obvious possibility is
the power of their voice these passive
institutions hold very large stakes and
along with this comes significant voting
rights and so we find evidence that this
is in fact an important mechanism
specifically we find that when passive
ownership is higher support for
shareholder governance proposals
non-binding resolutions is higher as
well furthermore we find that there's
lower support for management proposals
when passive ownership is higher
suggesting that management faces a more
hostile or a more discerning shareholder
base in some sense we also investigate
the possibility that passive investors
may be facilitating activism by other
types of investors for instance it could
be that if an activist investor can get
just one or two of these large passive
institutions on its side this may
ultimately increase the chances that an
activist campaign will succeed however
we don't find any evidence that that's
actually the case if anything we find
that hedge fund activism declines when
passive ownership is higher and so this
suggests that passive owners may be
pre-empting the need for activists to
come in in the first place finally we
turn our attention to performance
presumably passive investors care about
corporate governance because they think
this will lead to improved firm
performance but it's not necessarily
clear if we should expect this to be the
case first the value implications of any
of these specific governance provisions
so things like independent directors on
the board is widely debated in the
academic literature furthermore there
could be concerns that these investors
are following a one-size-fits-all
approach to corporate governance and
this is something that may not be good
for firm performance however we find
that on average long-term performance
improves when passive ownership is
higher and so this suggests that the
governance reforms implemented by these
vet investors ultimately have long-term
lasting effects on real outcomes so to
wrap up while not active in the
traditional sense that is these
investors aren't going out and launching
proxy fights or anything like that we
find that passive investors are not
passive owners this suggests that
institutional influence is not limited
to just active investors or activist
investors and ultimately the findings
highlight the importance of voice as a
mechanism to influence managerial to
decisions thank you I'm impressed like
you have been to many of these and I've
never heard an academic presenters paper
in 10 minutes before thank you those of
you who were at the gist previous
session heard a large discussion about
whether or not its companies roles to
deal with global warming we say we like
to present objective research the
practitioner prize also i will quote to
you what one institutional investor said
to me she said I love this paper because
I can use it my board is asking me what
to do about the threat of global warming
to our portfolio which I think was
Damon's position if anyone has followed
any of the investor panels in Paris the
debate has moved far beyond what some
people seem to think it is people think
that there is a major threat to their
portfolio holdings when you're a
diversified investor from carbon risk
the winning practitioner paper is beyond
divestment using low carbon indices was
done by msci the team was Remy brand
Linda L ingly Sebastian lieblich
Veronique window and a drug scene I'm
going to introduce liddell Angley she is
the global head of MSG research ESG
research at msci sorry bout that Linda
and she has considered what should
institutional investors do about this
not what should necessarily corporate
boards but the fact of the matter is
that capital does dictate some responses
and with that I will introduce you to
Linda
we took the photo thank you very much
well it's really such an honor to be
here to receive the award on behalf of
MSC I'd really like to thank the
distinguished panel judges in the rrc
Institute we're very proud to be
donating our prize money to the CDP
which is the organization formerly known
as the Carbon Disclosure Project I'd
also like to thank the milling center of
course for the opportunity to talk to
you all of you today about our paper
this afternoon you can think of this as
a quick 10 minute break from corporate
governance talk to ponder something a
little more cheerful which is climate
risk you know let me start maybe with a
little bit of a quick background on msci
and how we came to do this research msci
too many of you is probably best known
as a leading provider of global equity
indexes there are today more than 9
trillion dollars of investments there
are benchmark to MSDS all country world
indexes we are also the largest provider
of environmental social and governance
research and analysis to the global
investment community so our research
agenda is always driven really very much
by the investment problems that our
clients face and this this paper was
particularly interesting because here
we're trying to apply objective data and
analytical rigor to an area and a topic
that tends to be very emotionally
charged and very politically charged and
where the the competitive landscape and
the technological and regulatory
landscape is very fluid and evolves very
rapidly all of us are very aware of the
fact that we're coming into the crucial
final days of the of the global climate
talks in Paris and whatever happens
there I think there will continue to be
quite a lot of uncertainties there's the
science itself is uncertain in terms of
the time horizons and the magnitude of
impact as well as the policy scenarios
and the technological change so up until
two years ago I would say all this
uncertainty had very much paralyzed the
financial community and what change was
that about two years ago the financial
community had to confront a a quandary a
kind of an investment and puzzled so
what was this quandary
and it starts with a scientific
consensus the consensus is that we are
heading towards temperature warming that
could trigger catastrophic climate
change and if we want to be altering
that path of warming and shoot for
something like a two degree Celsius
warming threshold that would entail that
we could still put a certain amount of
carbon emissions into the air now the
problem is that the amount of carbon
emissions that we can put into the air
would mean that we can really only burn
about one third of the fossil fuel
reserves that we have already discovered
so the question for investors is you
know what's going to happen to the rest
of those fossil fuel reserves and how
should investors really think about the
financial value that they've already put
on fossil fuel assets when there's some
chance and some probability that some of
it might become stranded and never come
out of the ground to realize the full
economic value that investors are
already describing to them so for many
of the world's largest institutional
investors were confronted with this
quandary they came to us and they came
to us with two questions the first is
you know what what is our portfolios
exposure to assets that might become
stranded either through regulations or
through technological substitution and
the second question is you know are
there any options besides doing nothing
on the one hand or going with what some
activists will be calling for which is
that to divest from fossil fuel
companies so in our paper we set out to
address these two questions so in terms
of thinking about a portfolio's exposure
to carbon stranded assets it's really
important to distinguish between two
different dimensions a potential losses
the first thing you want to do is to
identify holding companies that own
fossil fuel reserves so these are assets
that today we have to remember that
today these assets do not actually emit
any carbon at all they simply embody and
hold potential future carbon carbon
emissions they're embedded in them they
may have a chance of never
coming out of the ground now the second
dimension is that you want to be
identifying in your portfolio companies
that have fixed assets that very much
rely on burning fossil fuels so that the
most accessible example would be
coal-fired power plants these might be
fixed assets that might also have to be
abandoned if new energy sources became
economically competitive or if
regulations or carbon pricing or some
other kind of mechanism makes them
prohibitively expensive to run to the
end of their economically useful life so
when we do this exercise for the msci
all-country World Index companies which
is composed of the roughly 2,300 largest
publicly listed companies in the world
including emerging market companies and
we find that the risk of holding these
potential carbon stranded assets was
highly concentrated on the top twenty
percent of companies today that are
emitting carbon emissions actually
constitute more than eighty percent of
the total carbon emissions in the msci
all-country World Index companies and if
you look at actually the concentration
of the future carbon emissions that are
embedded in fossil fuel holdings of
companies in the all country world index
we find that just 13 companies are
holding fossil fuel reserves in the
ground that constitute more than fifty
percent of all the potential future
carbon emissions across all companies in
the all country world index so what can
investors do about their exposure well
in our paper we propose a framework for
really thinking through investors
options and because it's important to
recognize that of course investors you
have quite different investment beliefs
and goals and they differ along four
important parameters for example you
know their tolerance for short term risk
can be quite different that the strength
of their belief in this long terms
thesis about the risk of carbon stranded
assets can be quite different they face
very different levels of pressure when
it comes to communicating with their
stakeholders and then of course many of
them have different levels of
preferences in terms of taking a public
stance in influencing corporate behavior
this topic so if we think about the two
main approaches that you can take to
reducing your portfolio's carbon
exposure you can really relate companies
in your portfolio or you can use
selection and essentially exclude a set
of companies and from the universe and
if you use the selection approach or the
exclusion approach and you know it will
primarily give you the benefit of being
able to communicate with your
stakeholders in in a clear way because
it's much easier to be able to say or
you don't hold companies XY and Z it
does however carry a rather big drawback
of ignoring short term risk because your
portfolio could deviate quite a lot from
market risk and return characteristics
Nowra waiting is in some ways the
opposite is harder to communicate the
stakeholders because it's a more complex
technique however this technique does
allow you to reduce short-term risk
which makes this approach in many ways
from a financial standpoint more
practical for a lot of institutional
investors so let me quickly walk through
two concrete examples you know that
exemplify these two approaches so the
msci all-country world the aqueous
fossil fuel index exemplifies a pure
selection approach where basically what
we've done is exclude every single
company in all country world that has
any fossil fuel reserves and so this
this index is probably closest to the
divestment approach that some activists
call for here in the US and now such an
index would end up excluding about seven
percent of the market cap of the all
country world and because it has quite a
large skew away from the energy sector
you end up incurring about a one-percent
tracking error the REE waiting approach
is embodied in our construction
methodology for the msci a quello carbon
target index and here what we do is we
take a couple of steps first we target a
very low tracking error 30 basis points
for example to the benchmark and then we
use optimization techniques to
substantially reduce to minimize the
carbon reserves exposure and to reduce
the carbon emission so what we're doing
is reading every single stock in the all
country world index
in order to minimize exposure to those
two dimensions of carbon so with this
design there are no excuse no exclusion
that also an investor that is be
tracking that all the the low carbon
target index would essentially have a
very similar risk and return
characteristics as the all country world
index so from a financial standpoint I
think it's going to be hard to see this
which is why you should go to the paper
itself you're going to have to trust me
that the characteristics are very
similar now it is the financial
characteristics that have been very
attractive to many of the largest
pension funds around the world that have
started to pursue this approach but what
has really surprised everyone in terms
of this approach is how much carbon
exposure you can actually reduce while
not excluding any companies so on this
chart the lead hand bars are the the
carbon X of the carbon emissions and the
the carbon emissions of the the
benchmark that all country world the
middle bar is the low carbon target
index approach which you hold every
single company but but you we've
essentially re waited all the companies
and to reduce carbon exposure and then
the right hand side chart is the X
fossil fuel index where we've excluded
the companies that have fossil fuel
holdings and as you can see it is quite
dramatic to be able to see that that
with this approach of simply re waiting
all the stocks in the all country world
index you can actually get very
substantial reduction in terms of both
fossil fuel reserves exposures as well
as and far greater reduction in terms of
your carbon emissions today versus the
versus the exclusionary approach so the
upshot of our paper is that there is
another approach besides doing nothing
and beyond divesting I did say at the
outset that we you know our goal is to
apply analytical rigor to a topic that
really suffers from quite a lot of them
ideologically driven rhetoric but in
terms of trying to make an impression
with this audience that the you know
that it's really urgent for us to be
able to come up with pragmatic
approaches
investors can take today you know I'm
personally not beyond making a mortar
cheap emotional appeal and this is my
chief emotional appeal I didn't I don't
think that anybody thought you could sit
through a carbon talk without a picture
of a polar bear so here's your requisite
polar bear photo you know the topic
really is extremely important it is
urgent and I thank the RSC for the
opportunity to highlight an approach
that we think is both innovative and
very practical for investors today
um I want to just end by thanking the
milstein center I wanted to thank our
judges you'll recognize how the name is
mark Anson the chief investment officer
Acadia but former cio for CalPERS for
her maze for Duveen Cola Chilton who's
the CIO at Williams College Bob dan
houser the head of capital markets with
cfa institute gym Holly who's one of the
more underrated corporate governance
professors out at st. Mary's of
California who invented the phrase
universal owner Rob our own Robert
Jackson co-director of the mill student
center at del nino who is not a
professor but most of you don't worry
that she doesn't need the title to be
one I also specifically want to thank
mill see to get in the CFA Institute
they really pitched in and publicized
this we got more submissions than we
ever have before and more importantly
the quality the submissions was so
superb that we actually gave for the
first time ever honorable mentions 27
other papers many of which if they had
been submitted last year probably would
have won the quality went up that that
greatly you can see the papers and here
comes the commercial you've got a polar
bear i get a commercial at IRC institute
org everything we do is free and
publicly available you could also sign
up for our email the next three reports
they're coming out will be about CEO
disclosure CEO succession planning
disclosure control corporations and
their characteristics a hot topic at
this entity I know and risk disclosure
by companies and with that I have the
pleasure say you have a 10 minute break
you